hallo herzlich willkommen meine trocken
meldet heute gibt es bei mir kartoffel
kater und für dieses quartal braucht ihr
keine tätigen produkte benutzt keinen
maggi fix oder wie das heißt sondern
verwendet einfach die sachen die ihr
zuhause habt alles schön frisch und ohne
zusatz und konservierungsstoffe und die
wenigen tagen dies eigentlich jetzt für
drei personen braucht es 750 gramm
kartoffeln das geschätzte gewicht z 750
gramm mit schale wegen die etwa 1000
gramm
dann braucht ihr 375 milliliter mailen
ihr könnt auch die hälfte durch sahne
ersetzen
für die form braucht er etwas butter und
für die soße noch 1 bis 2 knoblauchzehen
und später noch etwas gouda oder anderen
käse zum bestreuen
die kartoffeln hubrich jetzt in
gleichmäßige scheiben des werden
4 mm
dann kommt jede knoblauchzehe noch mit
rein
die könnt ihr da ungeschälte eingeben
und einfach eindrücken dann die milch
jetzt kommen noch salz mit reinen etwa
ein teelöffel frische muskatnuss und
dann noch die vier großen arien
dies wird jetzt auf höchster stufe 1 mal
aufgekocht und dann bei niedriger stufe
etwa zehn minuten geöffnet und das müsst
ihr machen weil sich so die stärke aus
den kartoffeln freisetzt und sich mit
der flüssigkeit verbindet dann habt ihr
schon eine schöne soße und nicht so eine
flüssigkeit daneben
soweit fertig sind müssen sie jetzt noch
in die auflaufform die auflaufform müsst
ihr dann noch vorbereiten und zwar kommt
er noch ein bisschen butter drauf
das können sie einfach mit den händen so
ein spiel dann kommt er einfach diese
kartoffeln milch mischung drauf nur das
dann so ein bisschen verteilen und dann
kommt da noch der käse darüber dass ich
jetzt in gouda wie ihr könnt auch ein
emmentaler oder parmesan nehmen und so
etwa 4 esslöffel oder halt so viel wie
ihr wollt und der auflauf kommt jetzt
bei 220 grad etwa 15 bis 20 minuten in
den ofen und wo sie dann das fertige
kartoffelgratin ihr könnt dann schön z
probiert das leckere rezept auf jeden
fall mal aus ihr könnt natürlich auch
andere kräuter verwenden aber ich finde
eigentlich so kartoffelgratin fast
rosmarin am besten und ein bisschen
muskatnuss rundet das ganze noch mal ein
bisschen ab und ich freue mich schon auf
eure kommentare und beck und zeigten
einfach wie es euch geschmeckt hat und
auf ihre rezepte volt und dann freue ich
mich aufs nächste mal und bis bald
tschüss